fidèle au rendez vous d'octobre
le salon de l'auto a ouvert ses portes
renault est une tradition le président
de gaulle a inauguré en compagnie de
monsieur jamais ministre de l'industrie
et du commerce chez renault exportateurs
dans 98 pays
la floride que présente cette hôtesse de
nationalités différentes
la dauphine a acquis cette année une
nouvelle suspension baptisé aéro stable
qui donne à en juger d'excellents
résultats
chez peugeot le moteur à huile lourde
s'applique à toute la gamme des 403 il
doit permettre une économie de 50 % en
valeurs monétaires par rapport au moteur
à essence
autre innovation 403 et 203 sont dotés
du ventilateur débrayable automatique
amélioration très appréciable en
économie et en gagne puissant
parmi les 400 modèles exposés une
nouveauté française la face il ya dont
le constructeur aspirent au titre de
christian dior de la voiture
lang liens forts de britanniques acquis
l'étrange des coupures de l'ariège
confère un profil pour le moins
inhabituel
la cadillac dessinée par raymond le vix
qui écrivent ils là les verts se vend
mal
la falcon 14 chevaux que l'amérique
donne comme voitures européennes
économique
enfin la ds19 a fait un grand pas en
avant
la montre du tableau de bord est
maintenant électrique
dans ce cas je commencerai par acheter
la monde